[Música]
la Unión Europea y el Reino Unido han
alcanzado un acuerdo sobre el protocolo
de Irlanda del Norte El Primer Ministro
británico dijo que lo pactado
salvaguarda la soberanía de Irlanda del
Norte mientras que la presidenta de la
comisión europea señaló que el nuevo
marco de Windsor protegerá a sus
mercados conectamos con nuestras
corresponsales en Londres y Bruselas
el gobierno francés planea reducir la
presencia de su ejército en África así
lo expuso el presidente Emmanuel macron
durante la presentación de su plan para
el continente a días de un viaje que lo
llevará de gira por cuatro países
centroafricanos tenemos el reporte desde
París
las autoridades de Ecuador investigan el
asesinato del líder indígena Eduardo
mendúa Quien murió a tiros en la noche
de este domingo la policía detuvo a un
sospechoso por los hechos que se
produjeron en la provincia de sucumbíos
en el noreste del país tenemos el
reporte desde Ecuador
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez y
es para mí un gusto acompañarles
empezamos con la noticia de que Reino
Unido y la Unión Europea han alcanzado
un acuerdo para el nuevo protocolo de
Irlanda del Norte El Primer Ministro
británico Richie sunak anunció el
acuerdo marco de Windsor que modifica el
protocolo original y que según se
informó respetará los mercados y la
soberanía de Irlanda del Norte la
aplicación del nuevo marco de Windsor
será gradual recordemos que el protocolo
establece los controles aduaneros entre
el mercado comunitario y el británico en
un contexto post brexit dado que la
salida de Londres del grupo de Bruselas
acabó con la libre circulación entre
territorios para evitar revivir el
conflicto islandés Londres y Bruselas
Habían intentado buscar la manera de
evitar una nueva frontera entre Irlanda
del Norte parte del Reino Unido y la
República de Irlanda país miembro de la
europea sin embargo la solución de
colocar los controles entre la isla de
Gran Bretaña e Irlanda del Norte en el
mar de Irlanda no convenció a la línea
unionista de belfast
para profundizar en lo acordado vamos a
conectar en este momento con nuestras
corresponsales en Londres y Bruselas
Luisa Pulido y Esther Herrera Buenas
tardes comienzo por usted Luisa desde
Londres Qué cambios respecto el plan
original han hecho posible el nuevo
acuerdo en el protocolo de Irlanda del
Norte
Buenas tardes pues simplifica simplifica
el ingreso de bienes y de alimentos
frescos a Irlanda del Norte acabando con
el papeleo con la burocracia y los
controles actualmente por ejemplo el
envío de una salchichas frescas que es
un producto bien importante para la
dieta nacional desde Londres Abel Fast
el mismo país es casi que un trámite de
importación por la cantidad de
burocracia de papeleo y de controles que
requería y el gran anuncio hoy es que
esto se va a acabar aumentando entonces
la presencia de productos británicos
frescos en los supermercados para acabar
con ese desabastecimiento que ha sido
una de las constantes desde que el
brexit se hizo efectivo hace tres años
el Primer Ministro Richie sunak ha dicho
que se elimina cualquier sentido de
frontera en el mar de Irlanda entonces
además habrá también más disponibilidad
de medicinas esto es bien importante
cada vez que la autoridad de
medicamentos británico apruebe un
medicamento este estará inmediatamente
disponible en las droguerías y en los
hospitales de Irlanda del Norte las
decisiones sobre el IVA y sobre los
impuestos estarán a cargo del gobierno
central en Londres ahora viene una parte
bien compleja para el Primer Ministro y
es tratar de vender este acuerdo en el
parlamento
necesita dos apoyos bien importantes
primero los de los eurocépticos de su
partido el partido conservador que como
sabemos tantos dolores de cabeza han
causado a los antecesores de sunat Por
no querer tener ningún tipo de relación
con la Unión Europea y también con los
socianistas de Irlanda del Norte que son
fundamentales para que se restablezca el
poder político en belfas en Irlanda del
Norte Así que empieza esta noche la
carrera de Richie sunak por tratar de
convencer a su partido al parlamento a
los unionistas de Irlanda del Norte que
este es el mejor acuerdo que pudieron
lograr entre Londres y Bruselas Luisa
Muchas gracias vamos ahora con la otra
parte con la Europea
desde Bruselas le pregunto Qué
concesiones ha hecho la Unión Europea
para alcanzar este acuerdo
la verdad es que después de dos años en
que apenas se han movido las posiciones
la Unión Europea se ha flexibilizado en
una de las cuestiones que hasta ahora
siempre se había negado los predecesores
de sunaki se trata de que la asamblea de
stormmont que es el parlamento Regional
de Irlanda del Norte tenga voz y voto
para decidir cambios en regulaciones y
en normas europeas que se considere
afecten a la región por ejemplo en la
entrada de bienes si consideran que es
perjudicial para Irlanda del Norte
además Londres tendrá derecho abeto en
caso de que se active este freno de
emergencia que da más poder a Irlanda
del Norte y también más derechos y más
para decidir Su futuro asegurado también
el Primer Ministro Richie sunak además
los tribunales de Irlanda del Norte
tendrán en una primera instancia poder
abordar cuestiones de disputas
comerciales que afecten en sus
relaciones con la Unión Europea aún así
el tribunal de justicia de la Unión
Europea seguirá teniendo la última voz
porque en última el que habla En nombre
del derecho europeo y también en el
nombre del mercado único esta cuestión
el papel del tribunal de justicia de la
Unión Europea es una de las cuestiones
que habían envenenado más las relaciones
entre Londres y Bruselas pero aún así es
una mayor concesión así lo ha admitido
la presidenta de la comisión europea
Úrsula fonder Legend pero dice que las
concesiones son necesarias en Pos de la
estabilidad y a favor de la paz en
Irlanda del Norte pero para Bruselas
todo esto se trata de un nuevo capítulo
en las relaciones entre Londres y
Bruselas se trata de algo histórico Y
eso se ha podido ver claramente en el
buen entendimiento y en las buenas
palabras que han mantenido tanto sunat
como fonderlation hoy
Esther Herrera y Luisa Pulido entonces
Muchísimas gracias a ambas por sus
reportes continuaremos pendientes de los
detalles que faltan para la aprobación
de este protocolo y de la intervención
de risa y sunacanta el parlamento
cambiamos de información porque el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron
planteó su plan de relaciones con el
continente africano para este quintenio
en un contexto decreciente recelo por la
herencia colonial francesa y por la
continuada influencia de la ex
metrópolis en África macron habló desde
el Eliseo A solo días de un viaje que lo
llevará por cuatro países africanos el
mandatario francés dijo que su país
planea una notable reducción de las
tropas francesas en África y habló de
nuevas relaciones más recíprocas y
equilibradas escuchemos
ya no hablamos de las bases militares
como existen hoy mañana nuestra
presencia se inscribirá
en las escuelas en las academias
congestionadas habrá personal Francés
pero
en menor cantidad y personal áfricano
y sin nuestros amigos africanos lo
desean podrán recibir otros socios de
acuerdo con los intercambios que he
tenido esta semana con mis homólogos
esta transformación comenzará en los
próximos meses con base en el principio
mismo de la construcción con una
disminución visible de nuestros
efectivos el presidente francés también
habló del despliegue de sus tropas en
Mali enviados para el combate contra
grupos yihadistas macrón resaltó el
trabajo de sus efectivos pero fue claro
al decir que no quería que Francia se
convirtiera en un chivo expiatorio en el
Continente por eso nunca dejaré que el
sacrificio de nuestros militares se vean
manchados con esa amalgana no quiero que
esta situación se reproduzca no quiero
que haya una engranaje de sustituciones
para que hagan que hagan que Francia se
convierta en un chivo expiatorio vamos
ahora a París con nuestra periodista
Natalia Ruiz Natalia Buenas tardes para
usted qué más podemos destacar del plan
de macron para su relación con África
Así es muy buenas tardes pues además de
todo esto que estas precisiones que hizo
Emmanuel de esta gira por África Central
es importante ver que una vez más toca
el tema de querer de verdad pasar la
página lo había anunciado en su discurso
en agua eso fue en 2017 y hoy una vez
más vuelve a decir que a partir de ahora
comienza una nueva era en las relaciones
entre Francia y el continente africano
unas relaciones de mucho más equilibrio
de mucho más respeto también y sobre
todo con Francia tratando de dar una
visión bastante humilde aceptando los
errores que se que se pudieron cometer y
también habló acerca de algo que ha sido
importante también para algunas naciones
africanas y es la restitución de bienes
culturales Manuel dijo que en las
próximas semanas habría la presentación
de un nuevo proyecto de ley para nuevas
restituciones restituciones que ya se
hicieron hace algunos años a Costa de
Marfil pero también más recientemente
fue hace un par de años y sobre todo
pues estas piezas que muchas veces se
encuentran en los nacionales pues
necesitan cada una de una ley precisa
por cada una de de de digamos de estas
restituciones que además debe ser
aprobado por el parlamento Así que esto
también da paso a un a un nuevo digamos
a un nuevo comienzo o digamos una nueva
etapa en las relaciones entre entre
Francia y África sobre todo también pues
esto da pie a digamos a dar un sentido y
a mostrar a qué va Emmanuel maco de
nuevo al continente africano esta Será
su visita número 18 a ese continente y
justamente cuando todo ese sentimiento
antifrancesa ha venido creciendo en el
en en varios países africanos
especialmente en Mali especialmente en
burkina faso dos de los países de los
que los militares franceses tuvieron que
salir unos en agosto y más recientemente
ya cuando Se confirmó se oficializó eso
hace una semana
Natalia Muchísimas gracias por el
reporte Seguiremos Cómo se materializan
estas promesas y también esta gira
africana del presidente francés durante
esta semana nosotros cambiamos de
información porque en Ecuador la policía
Investiga el asesinato del líder
indígena Eduardo mendúa quien fue
tiroteado la madrugada de este domingo
en sucumbíos en el noreste del país
cerca de la frontera con Colombia
nuestro corresponsal en Ecuador Gustavo
Ortega con los detalles y las
potenciales consecuencias del incidente
el asesinato del dirigente de relaciones
internacionales de la confederación de
nacionalidades indígenas de Ecuador
Eduardo mendúa ha generado reacciones no
solo en el país sino el propio
representante de los pueblos indígenas
de la ONU el presidente del foro
permanente de asuntos indígenas de la
ONU Darío Mejía Montalvo calificó el
asesinato como repudiable y altamente
preocupante exigió las autoridades
actuar con rapidez y castigar a los
responsables Eduardo mendúa fue
asesinado el 26 de febrero al estilo
sicariato según informó el ministro de
interior pata cuando retornaba a su
vivienda en la provincia de sucumbíos
por un grupo armado formaba parte de la
nacionalidad indígena cofaán que hace
vida en la he amazonía ecuatoriana su
más reciente participación se produjo en
la asamblea nacional de la conae en la
ciudad de Quito donde los movimientos
indígenas le han exigido la renuncia al
cargo al presidente de la república
Guillermo lasso por una supuesta trama
de corrupción y narcotráfico que señalan
a su entorno más cercano sucede cuando
hace siete meses también su hermano
fuera asesinado a las organizaciones
indígenas desconfían de los pedidos de
investigación del ejecutivo nacional y
han rechazado la presencia de la
actividad minera y petrolera en sus
territorios sin consulta previa los
movimientos indígenas de rechazan la
militarización en 30 nuevos pozos
petroleros y 11 explotaciones mineras y
aseguran que tanto el presidente de la
república como la empresa petrolera
Estatal tienen cuotas de responsabilidad
por la militarización de sus territorios
y cuotas responsabilidad por la omisión
de la seguridad en sus zonas sucede en
medio de un clima de atención política
en medio de investigaciones el
presidente de la república los
movimientos indígenas anunciaron
previamente que radicalizarán la
vigilancia a sus territorios y harán una
nueva asamblea para evaluar lo sucedido
mientras la fiscalía anunció la
detención de un primer involucrado en el
asesinato y continúa la escalada de
violencia en el conflicto desatado por
la ocupación israelí ayer un miliciano
palestino mató a dos israelíes en
cisjordania ocupada en respuesta decenas
de colonos israelíes atacaron y quemaron
vehículos y casas de palestinos ante lo
que las organizaciones por derechos
humanos han definido como La
indiferencia de las autoridades
israelíes el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu pidió a los colones no tomarse
la justicia por su cuenta y el ministro
de seguridad venga abir aseguró que
corresponde al gobierno eliminar a los
palestinos terroristas veamos
Carlos y casas en llamas son imágenes de
las disjordania ocupada un acto de
venganza realizado por colonos israelíes
previamente en la misma zona de jugará
dos israelíes fueron asesinados mientras
conducían un acto terrorista palestino
según el gobierno israelí pero de
momento nadie ha reivindicado la autoría
ante este recrudecimiento de la atención
en los asentamientos Benjamín llamó a la
calma
las fuerzas de defensa de Israel y las
fuerzas de seguridad persiguen
actualmente al asesino lo encontraremos
lo capturaremos y nos ocuparemos de él
les pido Aunque la sangre siga caliente
y los ánimos caldeados que no se tomen
la justicia por su mano y dejen que las
fuerzas de seguridad hagan su trabajo
en el lado palestino las autoridades han
contabilizado al menos un muerto cerca
de la blues en esta misma ciudad tuvo
lugar Hace unos días la última de las
numerosas incursiones de las fuerzas
israelíes estos ataques se han
asumió el poder hace dos meses solo
desde principios de este año han muerto
al menos 63 palestinos y 11 israelíes un
recrudecimiento de las tensiones a la
vez que representantes palestinos e
israelíes se han comprometido a una
desescalada en la región tras una
reunión en Jordania
a ustedes Muchísimas gracias por su
atención sigan con más información
[Música]